[Music]
when i was a younger actor are people
sick of me saying that a lot of the
episodes started i know that i just
realized that but uh a lot happened to
me then and i've been in quarantine for
last year you've also never been an old
man actor yet that's true maybe one day
i'll say when i was an old i mean i was
a middle age actor yeah but um i
once auditioned for
dawson's creek which was one of my
favorite shows uh as a younger man you
recently re-watched it didn't you i i
was wondering if you were going to out
me for that oh it's not an outing it's
kind of i rewatched the whole series
yeah but like 10 15 20 years ago right
um it's it was great and if you're
judging us right now shame on you
because you know you love it but it's
also our childhood so
um and you know there's joey potter i
had two pet frogs oh when i
with my first girlfriend when i was in
high school
named name of
dawson
and joey you're kidding no how did i not
remember that what kind of frogs i don't
remember little ones
where'd you get little green ones where
did you get them pet store what you
bought little frogs they need homes too
no no i'm not i'm not shaming you i'm
just surprised knowing how little you
it was like
it was like 23 years ago so did she want
the frogs i think so i bet
anyway uh that's not the story no here's
that is a story should we just go with
that yeah okay life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your frog loving host justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
and with me as always is um uh my i
guess closeted frog lover as well
up up until now
now i feel bad for stepping on your
story yeah wow well you can tell it now
okay well i once
i once auditioned for dawson's creek and
it was for um
a role that i was really wrong for it
was um it was for like the
the cool jockey rebel that comes into
town like the new the new guy in town
why do you say you're wrong for
well why would you think i was uh
brown hair they're looking for a more
blonde part of it that's part of it i
just didn't feel like that guy at all it
was hard for me to be naturally that guy
to put myself in that position and it
was one of those auditions where i'm
reading with a casting director who's
not really it's not like i have a scene
partner that's like it's not like katie
holmes is in the room oh it was the
casting director's fault that he didn't
get the role of the hunky
boy next door well actually
the guy who got it isn't like a um
classical hunk i would say michael pitt
the actor michael pitt if you remember
him he's he's quite a hug he's he's very
he's handsome he's very handsome but
he's but he's also but i'm saying he's
not like a
big
hunky
like a classical well i remember that
hockey i remember that role yeah um
i was i even remember the name of the
character who was him henry oh yeah oh
my god
oh yeah because you re-watched it a
couple years yeah and a couple months
ago he uh he was jen lindley played by
michelle williams uh-huh love interest
and
he was younger than her and that led to
problems in the relationship because he
wasn't mature enough right to handle the
uh quite precocious jen lindley uh but
he was she was uh she was intrigued by
him because he was
kind of quiet and mysterious and he was
young he was brooding and sensitive well
that's the thing i it required the
audition i remember required that i'd be
cool and brooding and all those things
that you just mentioned and i didn't
feel like any of those things and so
rather than
act the part um i got very
self-conscious and i tr and i tried to
too hard to perform it and so i sometime
i think about that audition only in the
context of you know when like in
audition some bad audition gets leaked
like i don't want to say
who's but you know we've seen
bad auditions or maybe not but they do
sometimes and i always think uh oh god
i would be so mortified if that one
that's the one i think about getting
late because i i'm not being
self-deprecating like i know it was bad
it was embarrassingly bad i bet trying
to be cool and like hey and
yeah
why are we talking about dawson's creek
that's a very good question well
dawson's creek at the time was on a
network called the wb
if if you give you kids remember that um
and then the wb became the cw but they
kept the general type of programming
which is and the general type of fan
base yeah yeah and
generally speaking um actors
much like the ones who were on dawson's
creek uh were employed by this network
including our guest today
the very talented very uh cw
attractive cw lee has that ever been an
adverb i doubt it
cat mcnamara
cat um
you don't think anyone's ever said that
cw lee
i'm sure someone has said it
like by accident yeah
it's short for catherine right yes
catherine mcnamara um should i
i don't know what to call her now i mean
we get into that friends first call her
different things but professionally yes
you're right she's known as catherine
mcnamara um
but you know now i consider her a friend
yeah you have a rapport now right so to
me she's now cat mcnamara so sorry
but uh
and to some of you she may be different
nicknames but uh to the majority of you
she's probably catherine uh so you're
about to hear she's on an extremely
popular show that has
a rabid fan base i think it's fair to
say uh called well they're not
necessarily rabid
not they don't have rabies no no but
they're not
but you don't know that they're they're
it's a big fan base i imagine they're
fairly some of them are rabid
all right
it's called uh do you have a bad
association with rabbids well you rabies
i think you're right you do yeah rabid
rabid a rabid dog who else is rabid
fans yeah but i think of rabid fans
being like really like aggressive and in
your face oh really
oh i don't i don't what's your well
maybe i'm wrong maybe rabbit is more
pejorative than i'm thinking it well i
think it it should i be saying avid
let's see but that sounds weird avid
fanbase i think you're probably right
you're right to say it it's descriptive
enough and it i i know for the record i
just mean that the fans are really into
the show i don't mean they have rabies
though i'm sure some of them do you
think i'm sure some fans of
shadowhunters have
rabies
i think race is very rare i don't think
you have it for a length of time maybe
some fans of shadowhunters have had
rabies anyway she's on a as you
mentioned shadowhunter is a very popular
show but that's actually on um another
network
yeah that's on freeform
and or was on freeform uh for a couple
years and that has a huge following but
she's it's cw adjacent it is but most
recently she was on uh the cw show green
arrow
arrow yes i almost said lanterns you
know what's funny if we're getting
potentially new listeners like huge cat
mcnamara fans tuning in to this episode
you can't call her you don't know her
all right catherine mcnamara huge
catherine mcnamara fans who are
tuning in just because she's the guest
two middle-aged guys
they've only heard two middle-aged guys
talking about dawson's creek
they definitely are not gonna make well
they're or they're fast forwarding they
can fast forward yeah yeah they know how
to do it they're they're kids they're
millennials they're hip they know more
than we do how to do it so uh if you've
gotten to this point she's also in um
oh yeah hit movies yeah she's in tons of
stuff and she's a wonderful theater
actress i saw her we did the 24 hour
plays together we talked about that uh
and she's very active in the 24 hours
she plays she's um does a lot of stuff
for charity she's a really good person
um and she uh recently is well is going
to be very soon in the stand the
adaptation of the stephen king i'm
excited for me too i can't wait so uh
hopefully you can't wait for um my chat
with a very lovely uh very bright
catherine
cat i call her cat you can i guess
mcnamara life could be a dream
sweetheart
hello hello again
[Music]
i just started watching shadowhunters
i'm i've seen 25 minutes of your show
and uh oh my goodness and i'm really
upset because um
uh i'm like in i'm hooked i'm into it
and i don't want another thing to be
into
uh but it's really fun and
pulpy and kind of soap opery um i really
want to talk about it and and the acting
on it and all that but um
yeah it has a very loyal fan base as you
said and so you've been going to how
often do you go to these conventions
well in a normal world i used to go
every at least once a month to something
somewhere in the world whether it was a
shadowhunters convention or a
multi-fandom con or something because
they have uh you know between i've
somehow fallen into this world of doing
a lot of these
comic-con genre projects whether it's
maze
what was the first one cat that you did
was it by the way what should i call you
a cat is great okay i like cats call me
cat okay okay can we say that you're
from uh lee's point lee's summit kansas
city is the best like because there's so
many little suburbs in that area
kansas city is the main like okay all
right i went down this whole lease
whatever we won't say it but i went down
this whole lee's summit like wikipedia
yeah
is that what it's called
lee's summit i actually grew up kind of
at a weird intersection of a bunch of
little towns in
in the kansas city area and
i
i love growing up in kansas city because
it was such a
wonderful grounded place to grow up
especially now that i kind of travel all
over the world and live in so many
different places you appreciate it
i really do having that as a home base
also best barbecue in the world i will
i will fight people on it oh yeah i've
heard you've been to kansas city passed
through but never spent enough time to
like to try out the barbecue i know it
sounds like a very nice place to to grow
up it's really wonderful and actually
going back now it reminds me a lot of
nashville sort of 10 years ago they're
they're the town's completely changing
and it's growing and it's kind of
growing up as it were um which i love
seeing just because i'm i'm so proud of
this little hometown and it's
it's modernizing in a way that um you
know i'm so so happy to see i also
you know kind of say that i was raised
artistically in the kansas city theater
community a lot of people don't know but
there's a lovely amazing little pocket
of professional theater in kansas city
that is full of people that do it for
the art and do it because they love it
and just everybody does every job and
there's no ego involved and all it is oh
i don't like that a bunch of people
doing theater and and making heart
because they love it and and i just
was so grateful to have that sort of
work ethic as my base yeah moving
forward how did you get into that like
how did you discover that community
uh completely by accident
so as a kid i come from an entirely
science and medical based family
everybody in my family does something in
that field and i was a huge math nerd
science was never really my thing
but i ended up loving economics so i
wanted to go into developmental
economics as a kid that was like most
kids my dream yeah of course you know i
i was balancing the checkbook at age
seven and i thought that was more fun
than you know going outside to play
that's crazy you love how did you
develop do you remember early uh
experiences of that like how you fell in
love with something like that that is an
odd thing for a kid to gravitate towards
i do i i had an amazing teacher her name
is miss vicki i'm still friends with her
to this day
um i went to miss vicki so it's all
thanks to miss vicki and and to really
my family um i went to a montessori
preschool and she saw this sort of
love for learning in me and this little
spark and she decided to foster that and
so she really encouraged me and pushed
me and pushed me to to read and to do
multiplication and division and all of
these things beyond what you're supposed
to be doing at that age does it work she
was your preschool teacher
yeah oh my god that's incredible
so
she
taught me to love learning and between
her and my family learning for me was
always this kind of journey of discovery
and this fun thing it was never a chore
it was always an opportunity to to
discover something new for yourself and
to sort of be self-motivated to
expand your horizons wow so so were you
often left to your own devices were you
like
was was part of that curiosity foster
just because you were kind of on your
own and like having to
fill the time
a little bit part of it i i feel like
part of why i became an actor in
retrospect is just living in my own
imagination and
making these whatever situations but
also whatever my
parents or grandparents were doing it
became a game i spent a lot of time with
my grandparents growing up and
my grandfather if he was working in the
yard you know it was
i got to go ask him what he was doing
and learned about it or if he was you
know re fixing the car engine or the
lawn mower or something it became how do
engines work and let's see how this goes
and let's learn about this so he had so
you know yeah he had stuff to do people
were doing stuff around you like adult
stuff like life stuff
and you were just you were there and so
they had to like look i love that they
had to look after you and so they part
of their
they they you just started absorbing the
stuff that they were doing that that's
really cool yeah and it made me love
learning which is i think why i i love
school so much i loved math so much and
then when i found out that these you
know huge
scaling life
altering
country altering forces of economics
could be explained in math formulas and
charts and sort of boiled down to these
concepts it blew my mind
um so that's what i thought i was going
to do with my life
so far the only thing we have in common
is we both own astronaut onesies
well there we go yeah but then wait
sorry to interrupt you i just i'm
fascinated by this that this was your
this was something that how how often
would you you you mentioned miss vicki
how often would you see her like how
much of a presence was she in your life
well she was my teacher for several
years as a kid like when i was really
really young like maybe three to
six or so when you develop a love for
economics
yes exactly
and then she and i became friends and
obviously you know she was friends with
my mom and we sort of
just stayed in touch throughout the rest
of my life yeah and it's i'm so glad to
to have her part of my life because i've
watched her
be that same force for so many other
kids still teaching you know
i believe she is yeah and my my mom's a
uh she's a science a research scientist
but a professor as well and so i have a
love for teachers and such an
appreciation for them yeah my dad was a
teacher growing up my both my parents
and my older brothers as well uh
yeah that's really cool what is your mom
what type of research
uh infectious diseases is her specialty
well
perfect what a time wow what is she how
is she
is she working on it she's been a great
resource this year um yeah why she's
yeah well she's pretty much a teacher
now but it with all the information and
all the misinformation that's been going
on this year just having her to be able
to call and go okay when do i freak out
when do i stock up what what what's
actually going on what's the scale
what's the freakout scale like give me a
number that i should be exactly zeroing
it on
wow that's so cool my mom is kind of the
opposite she'll just um you know she'll
read any whatever like fear-based
article pops up on
on her like click bait and she's like oh
my god you have to stay away from maple
trees
that's how it's being spread um
you're so lucky that's so cool well see
that's me i'm like mom do i need to stay
away from maple trees i've been hiking
what do i do i gotta go outside i gotta
get fresh air yeah no it's fine just
wash your hands don't touch your face
wear a mask is that kind of i mean like
according to your mom is that kind of
where we're at still
that's pretty much until we get a
vaccine ultimately that's kind of where
we're at is you know social distance
when you can wear a mask wash your hands
don't touch your face i'm so curious
about her now can we get her on the show
too sure i'm sure i could talk to her
about it um she's very shy though it's
so funny she's extremely shy when it
comes to you know public things yeah i
have to you know i i did the when i did
shadowhunters for for so many years i
had to convince her to come to set
because she doesn't like coming to work
because it's it she feels like she's in
the way and it's not her environment and
it's
it's very interesting where do you shoot
that show because i was trying to figure
it out i know it's not new york only
because um
only because i love when they do like
this like the brooklyn brewery and they
always make a point every the production
designers like every scene is gonna have
like a sign that says brooklyn or queens
or it's so it's like all right calm down
i it's clearly not there
um it's like the brooklyn bridge and uh
i i first i thought new orleans but then
i started thinking canada like maybe
toronto bingo
oh i'm very proud how so you got to live
in toronto for three years i love
toronto yeah i mean so much me too it's
such an amazing town and it's you know
you're in we were there 10 months a year
for so many years wow
yeah we did 20 episodes a season
so it took up a lot of our time and
we never got sick of that city we also
had a really tight-knit cast yeah so
you know we all lived within three
blocks of each other and spent all of
our time together
those are my brothers so cool it's
matthew d'addario
who yeah whose sister was on the show
but it seemed like you guys must have
had a lot of fun making it uh doing we
really did we were very lucky we all
clicked pretty much instantly and i mean
they will be my brothers for the rest of
my life i love those dudes and they you
know i was 19 when i started that show
wow
and so you know i did that show from the
time i was 19 to the time i was 23 and
that sort of period of your life is so
transformative and so transitional just
as a human being oh i was still going
through puberty i i
was wrecked yeah
yeah
how did you then get the part was it
just through um the normal audition kind
of ways yeah
yeah i was auditioning in la and uh this
pilot came up and
you know it's funny you go through i i'm
very much in the mindset of an actor of
i love auditioning because you you work
on it you go in the room and you play
for those 10 minutes and you leave it
behind but there are some auditions
where
you read the script and connect to it
instantly and you just know that there's
a part of you that has to tell this
story
and as soon as i read the pilot for
shadowhunters i
instantly knew what this character could
be and what she could become and where
she could go
and
connected with her in a way that i
hadn't in a really long time what are
you so happy when it worked out oh
that's cool okay what do you think it
was about that character because she's
for the people who haven't seen it she's
um
she starts out kind of uh she's uh she's
turning 18. the mother has this like
secret this family secret um
and who which she makes very obvious and
uh you do a great job of not picking up
on her signals
it's like oh we have to have this talk
this very serious talk you're like
that's fine uh and then sh but she's
also an artist she's like a very kind of
sensitive spirit um what was it about
specifically that's that script that uh
you think you connected with
well
as a kid i always looked for
you know the female characters that were
strong and empowered and sort of fought
their own battles and were able to to be
individual and not fit a mold because i
never felt like i fit any specific mold
so you know everybody goes with the
disney princess tropes like mulan and
pocahontas were my favorites because
they were the ones that always i used to
have a poster of mulan on my wall as a
kid
he was so kick-ass yeah oh i'm aware she
kicks ass i do know that yeah yeah she's
she's amazing she kicks ass she runs
with the boys she like does her own
thing the whole movie was that when you
did you aspire to that or or did you
actually do that in high school were you
like that type of girl
woman oh i was always one of the guys
always one of the guys it you know i've
always had good female friends but
i think i just
connected i you know i played softball
as a kid i was a girl scout i did all
these things i i was basically the girl
who loves to play dress up and then go
out and play in the woods
yeah you were like a feral kid you
played around outside a lot oh for sure
i mean my grandparents house used to
back up onto all this beautiful like
woods and i would just run around in the
woods and play and you know
taste turkeys and do all that stuff
leaves yeah i read that turkey chasing
was huge in lee's summit in uh in canada
oh yeah yeah uh it actually is it is
it's funny there's a lot where i live
and um
i've always been tempted to run after
them uh what happens when you run after
a turkey they just
they just like run away yeah they just
run away and make a lot of noise do you
ever
do you ever catch them
i never have but i think the last time i
chased a turkey i was probably
10. i don't think i was faster well you
should try it again now with with adult
legs with adult speed i should shadow
pretty fast
it's true you know when you got to learn
to run in five inch heels you get pretty
speedy yeah wow
you probably did a lot of actions
because it's a lot of action it's it's a
very light it's a comic bookie
yeah
and i when i started that show i didn't
know how to fight at all i didn't know
how to hold a sword i didn't know how to
throw a punch i didn't know how to do
anything
and the stunt coordinators on that show
darren mcguire and his team they were so
incredible they used to train me like
three to five times a week and i had the
opportunity of being able to learn with
my character because you know clary was
this
artist who
kind of discovered this other side of
herself and was thrown into this world
and had to sort of find herself and and
find this power that she had no idea
that she had and also find a family
through that she learned to fight in the
process and that's something that i was
by my mid-season two i was doing all my
own fighting and you know most of my own
stunts which is just the best thing when
you actually can get gain a foundation
of the training as well was it something
that you picked up naturally because you
said you played softball and of course
you chase turkeys and so that must have
given you
some sort of uh athletic
foundation for for fighting
well how i started acting in the first
place i was a dancer oh and i've been
doing ballet since i was two um it's
just one of those things you know your
parents say try all these activities and
see what see what you like you know i
think they were just trying to see well
what does this kid want to do what does
she like what is going to be her passion
and other than math
other than economics
and you remember uh really enjoying
ballet ballet was my my life other than
you know school it was but i never
thought of it as a career just because
where i grew up and and sort of in my
family everybody had has an artistic
hobby but it's never i never even knew
that you know being a dancer or an actor
could be a job when you say you were a
kid who loved this thing or were you
just a kid who did the thing because it
was the thing you did or do you remember
like being like really like looking
forward to going to ballet
rehearsal let's say practice i did i
loved every minute of it there was
something about
in retrospect i was always on the road
to becoming an actor and becoming a
storyteller i just didn't know
that that was the end point you were a
performer you liked performing yeah i
loved performing and i loved the stories
i i would look up all the stories of the
famous ballet i knew every story line by
heart and i would watch them and just
something about escaping into the music
and hearing the story and the music and
and physicalizing that it was an escape
to me and and i never really knew why um
but then i ended up running into a
family friend who was directing a
community theater show and needed a
dancer and i said well sure you know i
was the kid who would try anything i'll
do something different for the summer
you weren't scared you were you didn't
have any sort of stage fright no i was
like sure i'll give this a go it never
hurts to try that was always my family's
thing it's like you if you don't know
what this food is try a bite yeah it
works if you don't know what this thing
is just try it and if you hate it you
never have to do it again wow that's
such a great thing to instill in a kid
that's such a great yeah mindset but i
remember walking on stage on opening
night of this theater show and something
hit me like a brick wall it's like this
moment of clarity that you rarely have
in life and i
i knew that i had to tell stories for
the rest of my life
and i knew that in that instant somehow
that i was put on this earth to do that
and be a part of this world was it just
describe it for the people who
who don't
haven't had that epiphany like what is
it it was it uh you just enjoyed it so
much you it was a kind of heightened
enjoyment because i i've had similar
experiences and i i always struggled to
articulate
how that felt
it's it's difficult it's almost i think
being the daughter of a scientist i
um i think through everything and i try
and reason yeah everything that's great
um
and
it's
it's a clarity and it's a certainty and
it's sort of an unquestionable truth
that just came yeah yeah at this moment
and and how old were you then kat
i think i was about 12. what was the
show cat what was the play it was the
king and i exactly and you know they
needed some dancers for the the royal
ballet that happens in the middle of the
show yeah of course yeah and then what's
the next step you just keep you audition
for the school plays that's the thing i
this is the beauty of the kansas city
theater community there's so many
opportunities of things to do and find
and people that are willing to sort of
guide
young artists as they're sort of finding
themselves and coming into themselves
and teach them the the hard work that it
requires but also the joy of it life
could
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
oh you graduated really early right from
high school i did yeah i graduated high
school at 14. yeah 14. that's like
doogie hauser and i got my i got my
college degree at 17 as well so it's i
just have been i'm a huge nerd i'm a
self-proclaimed nerd how did you do that
how do you get a college degree that
quickly um i was a crazy person and i
did 20 credit hours a quarter and i did
it in three years oh my god so were you
doing that from home you didn't go to
student life stay so i would have gone
to university and actually i was
planning on going to uh because i never
thought i'd leave kansas city i was
convinced that i was gonna go work at
the bank during the day and then the
banks close at five so i could make it
to the theater by curtain
and it was that was gonna be my life
i worked with a woman she went back to
new york
a few months later i get a random phone
call that says hey um we have an
audition for you
for a broadway show with catherine
zeta-jones and angela lansbury in two
days do you want to come to new york and
audition
and i sort of went okay but it turns out
this one this woman was in a little
night music on broadway in the revival
and they needed an immediate replacement
and she said well why don't you call
this girl you know she's in kansas city
but i think she'd do well and she'd be
great for this
so i'd never been to new york even just
on vacation that's crazy and i thought
okay well it's an opportunity to go to
new york i'm never gonna audition for a
broadway show again this is never gonna
happen to me again in my life that's the
treat uh just the opportunity just to
like they're gonna fly and they're gonna
fly you and stuff i ended up flying
myself but i i went out there i did the
audition did the call back in the same
day like trevor nunn was directing the
show getting to like meet trevor nunn
he's for people listening he's yeah one
of the most legendary theater directors
wow oh my god and that day to me was
just that made my life but then i was at
laguardia getting ready to fly home
about 40 minutes later and i get this
phone call and they say um
you did a great job congratulations come
back in a week ready to stay for six
months or more oh my god welcome to the
show you're how old at this point are
you done with college at this point i
was almost graduated high school wow so
you're which means you're like i was 14.
oh my god
oh my god a week later i'm 14 years old
living in new york working on a broadway
show the first broadway show i ever
physically saw on broadway was the show
that i was joining that's incredible who
was the woman who recommended you what a
nice thing her name's leanne larkin and
she is still to this day a dear friend
and an amazingly talented performer
catherine zeda jones was playing my mom
and angela lansbury was playing my
grandmother and then six months into the
run they left the show and bernadette
peters and elaine stritch came in to
replace them my god that's just let's
say that's just as good i mean being a
14 year old girl wide-eyed from kansas
city coming to new york and working with
these four women though they are as
leading ladies they taught me so much
i'm a 42 year old who's been doing this
for a while i'd be like oh my god
later on
elaine stretch rest in peace uh man
elaine is my hero she saved me honestly
in so many ways oh i want to hear about
each of them i want to well first of all
so catherine cedar jones do you do the
whole like oh i'm cat too and what do we
call each other little cat big cat
growing up i was always catherine and
then i started do when i got to new york
one of the guys in the show because
there were three catharines there was
myself catherine zeta-jones and there
was another catherine and one of the the
guys on the show pulled me aside and
said all right there's too many
katherines you're katie mac what was so
great about it is i i didn't have to
think about it and suddenly it's that
weird thing when somebody gives you a
nickname you automatically feel like
accepted yeah especially if it's
somebody that you look up to and who's
accepted yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so it was nice and i actually oddly
liked katie max so in new york city
people call me katie or katie mac okay
and then i moved out to la and i was
working with someone and they said you
know
i don't really like katie mac i think
you're more of a cat i'm going to call
you cat oh that's
actually that's that's a funny elaine
story i uh i walked in her dressing room
elaine's stretch i walked in her
dressing room monday and she goes
elizabeth
elizabeth
elizabeth and her dresser leans over me
and goes that's you
and then from then on i was elizabeth
and i don't know why she calls me
elizabeth i don't know
because she knew she knew my name was
katherine she knew everybody called me
katie that's a power move that's an
elaine stritch power move only i loved
it yeah of course of course by the way
she could call me elizabeth and i would
answer to it she was just a kick-ass
powerful woman i loved her to death she
also she i was in her dressing room one
day and she told me she's like
you know i'm going to 30 rock on monday
and you're going to meet me at my at my
hotel and we're going to go to set and
you're going to come learn something
with me you're going to come to set and
meet everybody and and spend the day oh
my god
okay sure so
was she like a real she was just really
like uh
she was very honest
yeah she played was she alec baldwin's
mom in the show
yeah yeah
so i go to set and i'm sitting in her
dressing room while she's getting hair
and makeup done she goes why don't you
go see what they're filming go learn
something
and so they call in a pa and you know
how tv sets are especially sets like
that they run like clockwork and
suddenly there's this little kid that
they you know they call a pa and they go
please take her to set you know miss
stretch says she's supposed to go learn
something and so i'm just sitting in
video village listening
i remember i was watching a scene with
jack mcbrear and he came over and he
goes
and who are you with you know in his
very lovely charming way yeah everybody
was kind of looking at me like who's
this stranger
[Laughter]
it's been such a crazy experience like
moving from kansas city to new york and
then i ended up getting a job
um in la actually
my first this will be funny for you my
first job ever in l.a was with beanie
feldstein oh no way
uh play no it was a it was a disney
channel pilot of all things oh my god oh
that's funny yeah so beanie yeah former
guest of the show uh so wait so but
you're
when a little night music ends and you
are now
14 15 years old do you
are you auditioning for other things
during this time are you thinking about
moving or doing something you're going
back to kansas city at that point i knew
i didn't want to go back to kansas city
because i was in love with new
york i just love that city so much and i
feel i feel it's heartbeat in me all the
time you get to a point when you're
doing
broadway as a kid where you reach a
height limit and you get too tall to be
a kid on broadway but you're too young
to be an adult
um
yeah i imagine i didn't know that but
that makes sense what's the height limit
it's
i think it's like 4 10 5 foot
what really and it at that point yeah
and i was i was like 410 when i started
night music
and actually
in a lot of broadway
kids contracts there's a thing where if
you grow a certain amount if you don't
fit the costume basically because the
costumes are so expensive they're
allowed to replace you
and i had surpassed that height limit
long ago thankfully they never replaced
me in the show or they didn't start
giving you like mickey rooney pills or
something like judy
you all like
you know growth suppressants or
something holy exactly
wow
so i was kind of too tall to do that
anymore so i had been auditioning for
film and tv which i had never done in my
life although i'd been doing other
things as well like i did i i have a i'd
like to say a small obsession but it's
not it's a very large obsession with
anything that lin-manuel miranda does
i had done
done a few readings and things of new
shows as they were being developed in
musicals and things like this and one of
them was a new version of peter pan that
was being developed by alex lackamore
and jeffrey sellers and all those people
that work with lynn and i i had such a
great time working oh you'd be a great
wendy
i was the first wendy in that
iteration of the thing and it was oh you
did it i did it yeah and it was it was
just like a reading you know for a
roundabout in the
rehearsal spaces that they do
but i remember being so
enamored because lin came to the
presentation
and i was a huge fan of his work and
knew you know kind of it was right he
had just gone back to in the heights
because it had just won and it was about
it was going to close and all these
other things
but
he came up to me afterward and pulled me
aside and said keep doing what you're
doing kid because you're doing you're in
the right place like you're doing what
you should be doing and just that little
bit of encouragement from somebody i
respected so much oh man so yeah so
getting to watch you know be a part of
that and watch hamilton rise and all of
those things but you know starting to
work in in film and tv and doing little
projects here and there
eventually got me to
booking a disney channel pilot which
took me to los angeles it was the first
time they tried to do high school
musical the series you're back like
almost 10 years ago now oh yeah oh i can
see beanie doing i can see you doing
that now uh so i was the mean girl and
she was one of my she was like my head
minion
and we had the best time just being
horrible to everyone oh i bet have fun
it's so funny because you uh that you're
playing that part and that beanie's
playing that part because she's such a
sweet she is such i mean you know
such a sweet person um yeah that must
have been fun for you guys
we had a blast yeah
to play mean girls
um and so then went so now you're
you're a kid in your teenager in l.a
did you do that a big job you did um
you did a big movie
yeah oh the money maze runner maze
runner sorry yes yes
with dylan o'brien really nice guy
love dylan yeah yeah and you did a bunch
of those right so i did the last two
there were three films and i remember
the first one had just come out and this
audition came up for maze runner and
literally they it's one of those you
know where they keep the script so
secret and they released maybe a quarter
of a page of dialogue for me to audition
yeah this is what they do when it's
something that's um uh like a hot
property like uh
i guess maze run which maze runner was
right it was like a huge series um
they keep it very secretive they don't
want anybody to leak the script so they
yeah which makes it hard to audition
because you don't know the context you
don't know anything about the character
exactly yeah maze runner was such a
weird one for me because i did the
audition and you know when you have two
lines and a quarter of a page you go in
and you do it seven ways and you go
i don't know what this is yeah
and i completely forgot about it yeah
you can't beat yourself up it's like
there are only so many ways you can
you can do those three lines yeah and
you're either what they're looking for
or you're not and it's you know it's
either meant to be or it isn't and and
that's kind of how it goes it's
fascinating that you had that mindset i
just it took me years to get to that
point you know of rejection and of
dealing with it in therapy and like yeah
i mean you know there are those that
hurt a lot more than others and those
that get attached to that don't work out
but i one of my first mentors she was an
actress in kansas city and she
told me one day she goes look
you know you're just starting out you
don't know a lot about this yet but just
remember that an actor's job is to
audition and you walk in that room and
for 10 minutes that's your performance
and you give everything you have and do
your absolute utmost of the thing that
you love most in this world for those 10
minutes for that audience in that room
and then you leave it behind you forget
about it you move on with your life
and if it's meant to be yours it will be
and if it's not
move on it's just such a healthy outlook
i mean i i i also think it really helps
the acting because then you're able to
just be present you know and not be in
your head
you're very lucky
oh thank you i've just always focused on
the joy of it what we do for a living is
we play
even at work sometimes you know even
when it's hour 17 and like i i don't
know if you're familiar with like the cw
shows do the big crossover of your all
the superhero shows yes and you're doing
one now you're on uh green arrow now i
got to be a part of the crossover last
year yeah as the the
new green arrow following up stephen
amell there was a moment that we were on
set and it was probably like hour 17 and
there was some big dramatic explosion
thing happening but i looked around the
set and i'm in a super suit and then
there's you know stephen amella's green
arrow and you've got the flash and a
couple of supermen and supergirl and
batwoman and all of these amazing
amazing people and you just kind of go
this is my this is my job yeah i guess
you just for a living this is crazy
that's really cool i know i know i i bet
i bet you have those moments
uh those moments are more clear maybe on
like when you get to see
iconic i'm thinking about like
characters that i grew up with that i
grew up like idolizing i mean you
idolize these uh
superman they're there they're in this
suit and the suits are cool and yeah you
must it must be really uh clear and and
you must go right back to childhood i
bet i mean never in my wildest dreams
did i ever think if you told me as a kid
that i would be doing any of this i
wouldn't have believed you for a minute
you're very active with chair we
mentioned 24-hour plays uh which goes to
charity but um you do a lot of stuff
with anti-bullying anti-bullying
campaigns yeah yeah um which is great
because i do i do i i do a bunch of pro
bullying things um so i'm curious what
the other side is
what drew you to that cat was that
something that you witnessed growing up
i was bullied a lot as a kid
and i feel like that's something that
you know in in different scenarios in
your life people go through different
things and and kids aren't always nice
um
and you know i was i was very lucky to
have
a great relationship with my mom and to
be surrounded by you know other
good friends that that helped me see the
other side of things but there are kids
that
feel really alone and and kids that feel
very isolated and you know if there's
ever anything i can do to
encourage just people to be kind to one
another it's something that people
forget so often it's just it's so much
easier to be kind to someone you have to
go out of your way to be
unkind most of the time and and people
don't realize that do you find that you
had we started talking about conventions
and stuff do you find
that is a message that is uh
being related at these conventions and
with all these different types of people
you know like
awkward kind of
different kid people on the spectrum you
know you meet a lot of those kind of
people
well i i feel like i'm fluent and
awkward i'm a very awkward clumsy
individual as well like many many
situations
so you can relate i can very much relate
and and i'm
what i love about comic-con especially
one year i got to go to san diego
comic-con and what astounded me about it
is you know i'm a huge nerd for so many
things like i grew up on star wars i i
absolutely love all of that and there's
so many things that i'm a huge fan of
everybody at comic con is a fan of
something but also there because they're
working on something so it's the sort of
mutual community of everybody's
everybody's just there to to nerd out
and to celebrate all these worlds that
we love and all these stories that we
love
and uh you know especially when we're
you know with shadowhunters i was
telling you a little bit earlier about
the community that they've created and
it's it's so nice to be in
a space that people are just there to to
be a community and to celebrate a mutual
love of something yeah and no matter who
you are or where you come from or
whatever about your life outside of that
everybody's there to to be a part of
something greater and there's something
so special about that that's so rare
anymore there's a real purity to
uh the fandom as well there's a real
like um
warmth and positivity to it's just these
and innocence like it's nice like uh
yeah and like you said you're a fan of
star wars still like i was thinking
about the other day a friend of mine's
auditioning for star wars and i was like
god i hope she gets it because like i'd
love to visit set and and um
meet c-3po i think i get like emotional
it's one of those things that you we
were all a fan of something you know i
shadowhunters is based on a series of
why a books i grew up
loving y.a and i you know
finally set up my bookshelf i i was
never without a book in my hand as a kid
and so i understand what those
characters mean to people and i
understand the the responsibility of
bringing that to life in a way that that
does justice to the source material but
also you know i i go through and i see
it's not just
the community isn't just about
us or about the story it's it's about
these kids connecting with each other as
well and you know i've gotten to have
the privilege of of being a witness to
this community and to watching fan
artists who were 16 when the show
started that are now selling their art
online
through
art of all different things because they
that's cool the fandom like supported
them and promoted their work and and
became a fan of them as well or i've
seen you know kids make friends across
countries and across the globe and find
people that they can actually connect
with and relate to and feel as though
they are a part of that they previously
felt alone i've noticed well that must
really connect with you because
you grew up you were an only child and
you were left to your own divide in
terms of connecting to others
i'm sure that's why reading was
important and
why star wars and characters like that
were you really
needed that's like essential for for a
kid in your position absolutely that's
cool i've noticed a cat that you do
promote
you put art up on your instagram a lot
other people's art like fan art and
stuff that's really cool i i never
i saw it as being something that could
go beyond
uh
you know
fan art right i didn't know that it was
a
but you know makes sense that's really
well 100 and there's i just i see how
much these kids pour their you know
their heart and soul into this art that
they make and the drawings that they do
and you know we we've all been those
kids out there that are making art about
something we're passionate about and and
just the fact that something that i you
know i get i have the privilege of doing
what i love for a living and it inspires
someone else's artistic impulse yeah i
want to do whatever i can to promote
that and and thank them for that and to
you know encourage that more often than
not i hear the the cynical take on that
which is like geez calm down this person
is really obsessed with me or like
really like you know
i've never heard somebody express so
purely the um positive outlook on it
which is you're like leading with
kindness in a way that's really uh it's
nice it's refreshing this year i feel
like it's kind of brought out
a lot of people's true colors in very
interesting ways and we've all you know
kind of dealt with it differently but
i think kindness is is the kindness and
compassion or kind of the key to
everything anymore
this year has kind of
been framed in a very strange way for me
because i at the beginning of the year i
just finished shooting the stand which
is a
the stephen king ministry i want to talk
about it yeah yeah
the trailer looks amazing thank you uh
wait and
why am i so who cares where you shot it
but where did you shoot it we shot it in
vancouver
okay um and yeah the stand is like well
yeah apocalyptic and it's wow that what
timing um
did they know that there was gonna be an
apartment
i really don't think so um yeah
making this project and then going into
this year and and almost feeling a weird
sense of deja vu for a minute
wait a minute this yeah yeah god that's
so weird wait you did you read the stand
when you were a kid because that was one
of the books i i love stephen king
probably not as much as you uh but i try
i couldn't i it was too it was too
daunting i remember and kids would carry
it around and kind of like bragging like
they were reading it and i think i even
carried it around for a little bit and
pretended oh you put your cat is going
to her shelf and right away she's didn't
even get off her chair to reach for her
copy of the stand which um
yes looks red it looks red
mine
wow it's a huge one and so how many
episodes does that set eight it's nine
nine episodes
and it's the whole book it's that they
got through the whole it is and what's
what's cool about this which you'll
appreciate is the stephen king fan
stephen king was a huge part of the
writing process of the limited series
and he wrote a new ending oh cool wow so
he took that over the book and
and went you know i don't i'm not
thrilled you know he he wanted to amend
it as it were and and say something else
uh and so we got to do that and it's
it's great oh that's that that's cool
because um
though i haven't read it um i imagine i
mean it was written in the late 80s
early 90s uh yeah he must have i'm sure
a newfound insight into what apocalypse
the apocalypse might look like and what
i'd be curious what he's gonna that's
cool
yeah sort of what i what i love about
this is that you know obviously once we
get through this kind of period of time
and in december when this comes out we
will have lived in this sort of new
world for almost a year
and
i think you know there's this thought of
are people going to be sick of pandemic
and and talking about disease and world
ending and things like this and what's
great about the stand is it's less about
especially our our interpretation of it
it becomes less about the disease and
less about the destruction of the world
and more about the people that are left
and what happens after
and and sort of makes a statement about
it's the choices that you make that
determine your destiny and what you
stand for that kind of says a lot about
who you are at your core despite the
external circumstances
yeah like how you behave in in uh higher
stakes situations like heightened
situations and that's kind of what you
were saying we're all
discovering now
probably not as heightened as
the stand yet
definitely not and i hope it doesn't go
there i mean especially
my my character is uh the the example of
who not to be in the apocalypse and sort
of um
the antithesis of what i hope people
will do
oh wow
how cool you get to play characters like
that that you seem so grounded and sweet
but you get to play characters who make
bad choices
it was a lot it was it was a very
interesting experience because i've been
playing heroes for a lot of years you
know doing the supernatural thing and
then doing arrow for so long it's you
know literally playing a superhero for a
minute um i haven't played a villain in
a really long time and it was cool
as an actor i loved it because getting
to do something different and kind of
stretch yourself in that way is very
interesting but
you know when you're on set you're
making character choices and you think
to yourself
you know what's the choice in the
scenario that makes me feel like the
grossest worst possible human being
and having that be the right choice for
the character
it's a very interesting headspace to
live in yeah i bet i bet when you do
something really despicable and somebody
and another another adult is like you
nailed it
yeah that that's a strange thing um and
julie's interesting she's you know she's
sort of this hedonistic
narcissistic
glutton of the apocalypse which uh is is
very
she's covered in glitter and fur and you
know all manner of things but it's a lot
of fun wow uh so she's not into the
masks she's a no masker no definitely a
no masker but you know getting getting
to live in the world of vegas and and
alex skarsgard as randall flagg is
just
who was the first one you said it all
takes place in vegas so
what happened to the story is it's
there's these two camps and like all the
good guys are with whoopi goldberg who
plays this sort of prophet from god in
colorado and then you have all the
villains in vegas basically worshiping
alex skarsgard
and uh it's it's fantastic that's just
that disparity that's right that there
are two different camps i do kind of
remember that because there was a there
wasn't there a tv movie in the i want to
say the early yeah yeah early 90s i
think i did see that so they had to
recreate vegas in vancouver
yeah wow it was amazing what they did
because they found this old um
like abandoned hotel basically and
created a vegas casino within it so we
had this all manners of extravagance and
and i wish i could go into more detail
but i'll get in trouble yeah no no no
and i'm to see it i don't want any
spoiler it's on hbo in december uh it'll
be cbs all access but yes
okay
well agree to disagree life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
hello hello again so we'll meet again
do you ever leave the house cat and
think like and immediately get this
feeling like you don't have pants on if
you forgot your mask oh 100
yeah yeah
yeah
it's so weird how quickly
that happened that we just adapted to
that it really is interesting i mean it
takes you know what 20
some days to form a habit technically
speaking oh really technically speaking
yeah i think it's something like 24 days
or something to form a habit as a human
being
and i'm kidding of doing it uh something
every day a repetition
and at this point i feel like like if
you get in a pattern and you do it
consistently for 24 days it will become
it
and at this point i was thinking about
this the other day we've all formed
habits upon habits upon habits upon
habits at this point yeah
that's true what happens what what
what's a good habit that you formed in
quarantine
a good habit that i formed in quarantine
i think like one that you want to
continue into um
your non-quarantined life
i've been better at picking up the phone
and calling people oh yeah me too yeah
which i actually like you know because
before we were able to kind of get out
and socially
distantly interact with people the only
thing i had was facetime
and and getting on the phone and that
that was
something i hadn't done in in you know i
do it occasionally but i hadn't really
fully utilized
that resource yeah it's not funny yeah
yeah speaking of the phone what what is
your most commonly used emoji would you
say
so i've been thinking about this
question i could probably say something
very sweet and cute and all that jazz
but if i'm being perfectly honest i've
been surrounded by dudes for so many
years i make a lot of really shameless
dirty jokes over text most of the time
so i would probably say the smirk face
over text it's sometimes hard to tonally
frame things appropriately yes
you're making a joke sometimes you gotta
you know just like set the tone with the
right emoji that's a good one actually
yeah and i'm a big fan of like the
double entendre in text because i think
i'm funny it's probably not it's usually
a stupid pun of sorts but if i if i
throw the smirk face in there it usually
excuses anything okay i like that and
that's the one they're kind of like
isn't it kind of like looking up a
little bit like yeah yeah yeah
um if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play oh uh
i was a softball pitcher as a kid
so i'd probably say baseball um can you
throw a curveball inside this is
probably a dumb question but can you
throw a curveball and you can you can
you can yeah it's it's a slightly
different mechanic obviously because
it's underhand as opposed to overhand
yeah you don't wind up more than once do
you you don't go it's been a while since
i've thrown anything but a classic pitch
i'll tell you that yeah please don't
please don't hurt yourself
please
i've seen a lot of girls throw out
elbows that way and it's not fun
and then you have to just pop it back in
right
yeah pretty much i think i don't know i
never experienced it myself so thank
goodness so would you go back would you
play softball again i would love to play
softball actually every year it's one of
it didn't happen this year but it's one
of my biggest joys because it combines
one of my favorite sports with kansas
city um there's a bunch of guys from
kansas city you probably know do the big
flick every year to benefit their
children's hospital yeah so that's one
of the joys of my life that i do as
often as i possibly can and we did it
virtually this year which we didn't get
to go play softball in the big stadium
but uh
it's it's such an incredible
organization and the hospital that it
benefits is called children's mercy and
they they operate very much like saint
jude where they don't you know if
families can't pay for the children's
care they don't charge the family and
they they really really just care about
taking care of the kids which is so
important and uh you know it was started
by
all these incredible guys rob riggle
david keckner jason
paul rudd and will forte who are kansas
city born and bred they're like the
pride of the pride of kansas city but
they bring a lot of us back that are not
only from there but
that they've all kind of worked with and
accumulated over the years cool it's the
best weekend yeah uh that's really cool
okay the big slick i'm glad you
mentioned that uh
and if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life what would it be i
would have to say bread and cheese
in any sort of like or it's one of my
favorite i mean growing up my my
family's um mostly swiss
so in every house we have good bread
good cheese and good chocolate
it's just it's kind of in our blood as
it were but i grew up eating it like as
a snack my grandma would make bread or
we would always have like really great
bread and just
hanging out doing it but then now that
i've traveled more too it's one of my
favorite things when i'm in a different
country like if i'm in paris i'll go
you'll grab some bread and cheese and
just wander the city and i really do
think i could survive on bread and
cheese alone man yeah i'm cheese i could
do without but the bread i mean bread
and butter i know i'm thinking about
like
really delicious hot breads that i've
got am i hungry uh okay what's your
what's your
swiss so chocolate too what's your go-to
chocolate
uh actually i i did this as a little
surprise i got stuck on a layover in an
airport in switzerland last year
and i stopped at i was it was near
christmas and i stopped to get some
chocolate from my grandma and my great
aunt and so that's kind of been our
go-to i got them a couple boxes of like
little tiny squares
so that's that's usually my go-to but
they've they've been like i get little
my grandma just learned how to take a
selfie
so
i get like selfies from my grandma with
her chocolate or with her tea in the
morning and oh man that's really cute do
they do they have accents they're not
swiss swiss so they're like no it's just
you i mean my grandma has a missouri
accent i'll tell you that much right oh
yeah family is from missouri what's that
sound like like how would you say um oh
yeah i mean
from missouri where it's hard to find
you you want to find good barbecue go to
missouri i have a weird time doing a
missouri accent because when i i was an
army brat so when i first learned to
talk i was actually i was born in in the
south so when i first learned to talk
this is how i spoke and i had more of a
north carolina georgia accent and then i
moved to missouri and i kind of lost it
somehow
so
my accent is like amazing yeah so my
accent is a weird amalgamation of a lot
of different things oh wow southern to
at what point did you end up then in
missouri i was probably like two and a
half when i moved to missouri but hey
okay i definitely learned to speak
elsewhere but it's always funny i always
i always put it this way when people ask
what a missouri accent is i see we take
all the ours from boston and we throw
them in where they don't belong oh
that's funny oh my god i'm trying to i'm
trying to hear that now um so like we
wash things and any art oh yeah
we're going over there to the harbor
yeah and and for example you know in i
always go back to shadowhunters because
i didn't realize i had a midwestern
accent until this but we we had a term
called downworlders
and when you're trying to say
when you're trying to say a word like
downworlders or werewolves or things
like that the r's get in the way
oh my god where where are wolves
where so how were you saying it in the
beginning
uh i i just noticed late in the evening
where just i i always noticed it you
know when you're tired and it's 4 am and
you've been fighting demons for 17 hours
it's hard to say words sometimes
yeah
that's uh that's an understatement that
uh it's hard to you just want to go home
and wash and wash up and go to bed
worship
worship um
what's your favorite movie of all time
so i'm really bad at favorites i always
say these and this may have actually
just changed in the past week um
but gilda with rita hayworth princess
bride and usual suspects it's funny
gilda now i want to see gilda because
those other two are so gilda okay yeah
it is clutching her heart
she clutched her heart and is very yeah
it's kind of the end of noir and the
beginning of kind of that old hollywood
glamour of like the 30s and 40s and it's
just
the film is just feels like velvet it's
like an old gangster movie starring rita
hayworth as this gangster mall who just
kind of runs the show but
ah it's just a beautiful film if you had
to live somewhere else we kind of talked
about this but where i mean the next
place you want to go but where would you
live if you could live somewhere else i
would love to live in london i just feel
like it very much has the same sort of
energy and pace as new york city
but with a history that we don't have
here in the united states if you could
have dinner with three people dead or
alive whom you've never met i have to
bend your rule a little bit because i'd
love to have elaine stretch at the
dinner just because there it's
so many things i didn't get to talk to
her about and say to her because i you
know knowing her when i was
14 15
now knowing so much more about her life
and yeah 10 years of of sort of being a
young woman in this industry and just
being a woman in general there's so many
things i want to ask her and talk her
about it and
discuss
um
it's just like great stories she must
have like they're probably because you
were 14 at the time i'm sure she
censored herself somewhat around you and
like no not even a little bit no filter
it's elaine there's no filter whatsoever
but she has stories for millennia i'm
sure
uh-huh um i would love to have i think
the economist and the musical theater
nerd in me would love to have um
alexander hamilton at the table you know
especially given the year that we're pre
the economy that we're probably about to
be entering we need somebody who you
know he's fixed it before he can help us
fix it again
and i want to know what he thinks of the
musical i i would love to know that then
the third person i'd love would be um
sidney lumet or sidney lemay i never
know how to say his name i don't either
he's that's always one of those names i
i'm afraid to bring up because i i'm not
totally confident in how to say it yeah
cindy lumet cindy lou may
sidney lumet i think it's danny lumet i
think it's lumet as well but i when i
was prepping to
shadow this director i read his book
making movies and was so
unequivocally like re-inspired as to why
i love telling stories because from the
moment you start that book you can tell
that it's yes it's written by a director
but it's written by a storyteller first
and foremost and that's something that i
would love to do
who's your who's your favorite muppet
oh settler and waldorf
oh yeah great they're the best they're
commentary uh
yeah
yeah oh yeah speaking of the best this
will be the best when it ends
um
yeah i love them and that they could get
away with uh
being such
it's so funny i never thought they were
mean you know
they said the meanest stuff but they
were like
there was something uh
maybe because they were old and like
they only cut to them every once in a
while
i never was uh turned off by them no
there's just an endearing sarcasm to
them and i i always loved it yeah if you
had to be one age for the rest of your
life physically what would you pick it's
a hard question for me because i i know
i know i know i i recently asked a 30
year old this and they were like man
28 29.
yeah because i would like to feel like
you know the the best is yet to come so
maybe i would say
30 33 maybe but
also i don't know 23 i was training and
had endless energy to work 17 hours and
train a bunch as well and i mean it's
still kind of in the same way but i uh
i would like to have that level of
energy for the rest of my life okay
if you could be um if you could be
reincarnated as a non-human animal i
would probably say a house cat uh-huh
yeah just cause i you know they lay in
the sun and they get to roam around and
have adventures of their own and i had a
cat that played fetch as a kid and
you generally are loved yeah would you
rather be called unattractive or unfunny
unattractive
i had this weird thing and i don't know
if it's that's not really a weird thing
but i i really don't
like the idea of measuring self-worth
based on appearances
and i think it's gotten to be such a
habit in our society but you know we've
there's so much more to a person than
your appearance and and your
quote-unquote attractiveness whatever
that's perceived to be
i find humor to be quite admirable and
it's something that
i love doing comedy and i aspire to that
and i'm in such awe of people who
are comedians and and are so funny all
the time that i i would so much rather
be considered funny than attractive yeah
you know it's funny i saw you um you
were on seth herzog's
uh
i saw some of the seth herzog's thing
and i was like how does cat knows how
does set well maura have seth no cat and
like how do they slick but
big slick that makes sense now yeah did
you watch the golden girls when you were
a kid i've seen it yeah oh okay which
who do you identify with dorothy blanche
rose or sophia so i i really do think
i'm somewhere between dorothy and
blanche
because i i'm very pragmatic and and can
be very sarcastic but also like i love
to have a good time um dogs are cats can
i say both yeah okay because i i grew up
sophie's choice that's sophie's choice
it's cat's choice but i can't choose um
no but i i
i love both i just love animals uh
beetles or the rolling stones i i guess
because i just worked at abbey road
studios i think i have to save the
beetles yeah god i mean it's hard that's
a tough one it's
really tough we were talking about
skittles the other day
are you a skittles person i do like
skittles i i would say as far as candy
goes i'm
this is my favorite time of year because
candy corn is
it's such a polarizing food but i love
candy corn
no kidding yeah i never got into candy
corn for some reason i i don't know why
i think i had a problem with the end
like it wasn't wrapped uh and i was
always a bit of a germaph i don't know
you just scoop it up
oh candy corn all right i i wonder
what's gonna happen this year if people
are not going to go out i don't know um
i
i'm trying to figure that out because i
obviously i love
dressing up for halloween and and
actually toronto well la but toronto is
an amazing town for
halloween i don't know if you were there
during that time of year it's so fun
never well because if you can imagine
like all the bars on ozington and all of
what toronto is yeah just that but
everybody's dressed for halloween
oh fun for some reason i don't know why
i thought it was an american thing and
the canadians might not really embrace
it but did you um did you ever go out in
your uh costume in your
um
no but that was vancouver the green not
for work yeah no we didn't do green
arrow but we used to do group costumes
as or we did it we did like a year or
two of group costumes of the
shadowhunters gang we would all go out
like dressed up sort of coordinated and
uh we had we had a good time
that's fun um i did a movie with john
heater once and he um
and we convinced him to go out there's a
local we were shooting in somewhere in
long island some small town in long
island and we there was like a local on
the local morning show i heard like
you know mike and the
mike and the
bear cat uh they were like we're having
a we're having a contest and i come on
down to mcswiggins and
and so we and the first prize was like
you know i was like a hundred dollars
for uh custom and we
got john heater to we convinced him to
go as napoleon dynamite we ended up
shooting too late so we didn't go i was
so mad i was i i was so looking forward
to this thing but um
we were all laughing like well what if
he came in
you know what if he didn't win
you know it'd be so
uh which would be funny um yeah it'd be
funny either way i guess
either way it's a great story and that's
all you want yeah it would have been
here's what's not a great story the fact
that it didn't happen
and it almost happened and i'm telling
you um
this is so fun i thank you for doing
this i i've just had such a good time
well thank you for having me i was
really honored when you asked and i i
have so many friends that love your show
and i love your show and it's been such
a pleasure thanks kat thanks for doing
this talk to you soon
[Laughter]
well that just happened
uh what were you thinking what was i
thinking why'd you say that so uh i
don't i didn't have much i was just
doing a generic um
we're having fun uh coming back from
oh i wasn't thinking of anything yeah i
guess that wasn't you both have to not
be thinking of something while you're
doing your uh catchphrase outro the
catchphrase phrase i know catchphrase
how douchey do you feel that you just
call it pretty catch phrase well it is a
catchphrase it's not necessarily ours
uh it's ours okay well now you've just
confirmed the douchiness out do you feel
douchey
uh
she'd have a catchphrase we have a show
it's douchey to refer to it and that's
true that's true well what are we
supposed to say about it i mean it's a
thing we do every show
well it's also difficult to talk about
shorties and call them fans or to refer
to yourself as uh having any degree of
fame see i can't even say i'm famous you
get so bashful when you say that word
fame it's horrible say i'm famous
i'm famous
it's really not easy it's because it's
gross sounding
also we live in that like a soundbite
culture so you know god forbid somebody
just
that's a quote i look somewhere and it's
like i'm famous next to like my name
which i also have trouble saying like us
weekly yeah
god um she's very very sweet great yeah
i'm very likely very sweet has and does
this make me sound old to say that she
has a
good head on her shoulders oh you know i
know this is kind of an old-fashioned
term in it
sounds like
yeah i know what you mean i don't mean
it that way no i agree with you i know
it's funny i've got that like impressive
she is bright she's like i know she's um
you said she was like doogie houser and
i'm not sure if she got the reference
because she's so yeah i forget how he
was born after that show was a show she
was born when like how i met your mother
was in its like third season
i don't know that for sure but i don't
think that's true no she was born during
i i bet when dawson's creek was just
coming on the air yeah
wow yeah but she is so um impressive uh
intellectually and and
and and emotions like an emotional
intelligence it seems that that betrays
her years
i will spit on myself oh my god
yeah and she uh you know i didn't know
that she had such a theater background
that she was a real like theater kid
well i'm curious now to see
shadowhunters uh oh it's kind of i don't
see i don't really it's a lot i'm not
hip on the trends no
i don't know much about the young adult
world the the yah world
um yeah queen
so i met her at the 24 hour plays thing
and we were leaving to go to like an
after party and a bunch of people got
rushed by autograph people you know
autograph seekers and um
i remember seeing her get like oh people
wanted her autograph and and then i
watched her show she's really good
really good actress and
you know i feel like i need to tell
people people who follow her on
instagram know this because she just
posted about it but um
she just got in a major she took a major
spill recently poor cat uh i was hiking
she talks about how much she loves
hiking she
and she mentioned that she was clumsy i
think in the interview
yeah she took this major spill and
had uh had to be
i think she was an ambulance had to come
bigger she had to she hobbled down the
hill and she has major likes
really [ __ ] up her leg really badly i
think she's off her feet now for two
weeks i don't know why i felt the need
to say that
it popped into your head yeah do you
have a podcast
and a microphone yeah yeah there's a
microphone in front of me and i'm not
great at self-editing uh amazing imagine
going to new york city from a small town
in
missouri yeah okay i i always like when
people call them missouri is that from
waiting for government that you think
about that uh yeah i do
but you guys in the span of
90 seconds you both said
missouri like 12 times i did i was
calling missouri back and forth missouri
missouri and i could tell you you were
just calling missouri because she was uh
yeah i don't that's not naturally how i
say it uh i say missouri but i what is
ur it's like oregon oregon i i've heard
once i may be speaking out of turn
but people from missouri missouri people
from there
say missouri and if you are from out of
state and you're like visiting and you
call it missouri you're like considered
a poser huh see i and i could be very
wrong i always thought it was depending
on where in the state you live
like certain parts of the state
shortages can you can someone
fact check us i could be wrong though i
should have asked her that would have
been a good question she also said i've
never heard anyone pronounce it this way
um
how do you pronounce uh sin city
oh sin city oh uh las vegas right me too
yeah i almost i almost said sin city
just like you said
that's all right do some people say
sensitivity
she pronounced it
vegas oh i've heard vegas you have yeah
las vegas she said that a lot too vegas
vegas i've heard that before that that
might be a regionalism regionalism that
might be
a missouri uh missouri
missouri way to say it uh i laughed when
you very excitedly
promoted her show that's gonna be on hbo
in december and it's not on hbo but you
said it with such gusto you're like this
december uh hbo stephen king's the stand
she's like inside cbs
yeah yeah
but amazing imagine being a 14 year old
girl
from missouri
yeah and going to new york for this big
audition on broadway and having never
been to new york well i cannot be like
oh i guess i'm living here for six
months as a 14 year old i know i mean
that takes a certain type of uh spirit
yeah that i don't have i pictured her in
those um
no i know she talked about going to
montessori school and she was like
my teacher just there was like a
found a spark in me yeah and as as she
was talking about montessori school i i
was thinking oh you know i went to
montessori school too in preschool
there's no spark no one saw a spar so it
was like maybe for a second it was like
no i just blended in
what is that who's that painter cause i
keep thinking in relation to cat the um
i keep picturing her in a painting by uh
you know that that famous pic
winslow homer doesn't she seem like she
she could be in a winslow homer painting
uh you know in the physically i don't
know i just she has that vibe like
growing up in missouri in a small town i
pictured her like playing in fields of
wheat
yeah chasing turkeys yeah that maybe
that's where it's from i i was surprised
when she said she then after saying that
she was
did all these things and she was so like
you know
um such a tomboy i don't know if i can
use that term anymore um but you know
chasing turkeys and like getting dirty i
don't think you can and then she said uh
she
was a ballet dancer
too isn't that strange and having known
some ballet dancers i know that that is
like a full-time
24 hour a day commitment i always feel
the need to correct you uh
just to clarify that you're not saying
belly dancer ballet yeah she wasn't a
two-year-old belly dancer no thankfully
when you asked her if she preferred dogs
or cats she goes oh hi can i pick both i
like both of them and you go yeah it's
like sophie's choice and then right away
you go it's not soaking choice
that's such a
such a wrong thing to say
uh i saw his choice it's not sophie's
choice it's it's i well i corrected
myself right away yeah
um i also thought it was funny when she
said you asked what her favorite emoji
was and she goes
ah well you know i shouldn't say this
but i've been spending a lot of time
with guys and a lot of like and so she
set it up yeah i thought for sure she
was doing like eggplants or cherries
yeah and but she was like like a smirk
face yeah that's right such an innocent
i know off to what i thought was gonna
be uh a filthy emoji yeah she has an
innocence that is uh really refreshing
yeah she's also young
maybe that's one of my youngest guests
and reminds me a bit it makes sense that
they're uh friends and they get along
beanie feldstein oh yeah that makes
perfect sense totally yeah they have
similar kind of vibes lightness and
pluckiness and i that's why like asking
them both uh like what age if you could
be pick any age it's like now yeah yeah
it's like something i probably haven't
been yet yeah
she's like three years from now
she's probably gonna be great can you
imagine i mean having a brain like hers
and having done the things she's already
done and being fatty being that young
it's like okay this definitely sounds
condescending but like
i'm just so
i'm so excited for her i'm so like i'm i
guess i'm not jealous but because i like
i think you'd be jealous of something
that you like but i'm like
i guess i'm a little jealous of her age
i think jealous is too ugly of a woman i
don't think it's ugly it's also hard to
be jealous when you're a 42 year old man
like you are yeah i try to be jealous of
a like a 24 year old blonde i know
actress we were thinking i know weren't
we talking about our nephews the other
day and i said something like that like
i i wish they're so lucky they have
their whole lives yeah you're not but
you're not competitive with a
three-year-old or with her in this case
yeah
um i don't know what the word is there's
you know there should be a word yeah
like uh a
non-ugly
jealousy yes like in japan i bet the
japanese have a word for it
don't you think they would have a word
for it they have words for things that
whenever i hear a japanese word that we
don't have i'm always i often think oh
man
we have jealousy we have envy yeah and
they're both ugly words
yeah it's interesting to think of words
like it's like uh that don't exist that
should there should be a word for that
yeah and you know there probably is we
just don't know it um
yeah they're probably yeah i know i know
we're giving ourselves way too much
credit
uh there's a word that i found um
that ryan phillippe uh put on instagram
the other day it was so good i was like
oh god i
why don't we have this word so the
japanese have this word for when you're
not hungry but you eat because your
mouth is lonely
it's called kuchis
that's like board eating right
yeah but i find myself i mean it's very
that's a privileged thing to say but i
find or like if you're you know stoned
or something that's different though
when you're not hungry but you eat
because your mouth is lonely when you're
stoned you feel hunger yeah that's true
but don't you ever like i i want to say
like
like late afternoons i find myself just
like hmm what's there to put in my mouth
i'm not necessarily like
you sound so privileged i know what's
there to play
i noticed that you eat chips in the like
mid aft mid to late afternoon yeah hey
let's read a letter okay great
letter from judson
i love batman i've always liked that
name there's a kid in our neighborhood
remember that there's an older boy in
our neighborhood who's probably only
like three years older than us judson
thumb i always thought he was so cool
he's a man now he must be a man now he's
def i mean
yeah probably 50. yeah judson this is
from judson up
do you think that's his real last name
up up yeah could that be a real last
name uh
judson up it could be it could be short
for like up upcoming that's such a
disgusting picture of me that you have
yeah and my phone yeah yeah it's so
horrible when i call that's the picture
yeah
this is
what do you have of me you have a gross
one of me i don't have any picture of
you oh thanks
subject oh no i do i do sorry gross
right no it's the old timey remember
that app oh yeah that makes you like oh
that was a great app yeah that you can
you can uh photoshop your face onto like
old uh-huh
you look like um
who's our the brito what's this oh ed
sullivan ed sullivan ladies and
gentlemen uh
ladies and gentlemen judson up that was
terrible subject to just to justin from
judson
oh he must get justin oh judsons must
get justin all the time it's kind of
cruel to name your kid judson yeah it is
i didn't realize that hello justin and
christian thanks so much for taking the
time or cruel to name your kid justin
well no because then people can be like
oh you mean judson i think i'm just
kidding yeah okay okay i almost defended
my name thanks so much for taking the
time to read my letter i'm a performer
on a cruise ship in the before times but
i have had my career appended due to
circumstances beyond my control
i have taken to listening to your
podcast to keep my spirits up in my
newly acquired free time no thanks
judson
justin based on my looks and personality
people tell me you are the actor who
would play me in a movie so i guess i'd
better get cracking at doing something
movie worthy
christian i only know you from this
podcast but i'm excited to see the film
that you and justin talk about i just
wanted to say thank you so much for all
you do for us your fans that is really
nice uh i lost my older uh boy i lost my
older brother in 2013. and i always
enjoy listening to your brotherly banter
here
it helps me imagine having those same
types of conversations with him i am
always entertained by both of you and
your special guest and it makes me feel
better about myself when i hear how
quote normal and human you are even
though you are celebrities i would
definitely nerd out if i ever met you we
could have a silly voice contest
i would love that i'm sure whoever was
listening would not
my strongest are gollum oh wow i wish i
could do a good golem gollum's tough
preparation
uh captain jack sparrow and michael kane
those are good ones i don't think i've
ever heard you try these well there's
probably a reason for that i've tried i
think i've tried michael caine everyone
sort of does him no no what is it that's
not terrible
pause for justin to give him a try and
we're back
i really do love your podcast sorry it's
funny to uh lump together gollum
captain jack sparrow and michael kane i
know just say call them silly voices
michael caine is listening he's nice
he might be
you don't know if i'm not listening
i don't like the way they presume to
know oh their fans are
um you know i know michael caine
probably best when i think of michael
kane what do you think of when you think
of michael um well bruce mr wayne i
guess i guess alfred you know i still
think of him from jaws the revenge oh
you do jaws four i because i watched
that movie so much as a kid i think i my
my first instinct was hannah and her
sisters oh my god yeah
not that long ago yeah that was the most
recent michael caine movie i've seen in
fact oh he's so good
um
that was my chair i swear to god whoa i
swear it's my vory pants rubbing up
against this chair well subtle
subliminal
uh yeah we love our you know both have
to love your new worry pants
sponsor okay um
i really do love you back to judson uh i
really do love your podcast i even tried
bud light seltzer per your
recommendation speaking of sponsors and
as justin would say it's a home run
folks
would i say that ah i don't know if i've
ever heard you say that i don't know if
i've judson it's a home run it's a home
run folks is i don't know if i'd ever
i've ever said that judson might think
you're a lot lamer than you think you
are
maybe not much lamer but a little lamer
oh my would you rather questions for you
are as follows okay great would you
rather be a ghost in your childhood home
where nobody that you know can see you
or hear you or live longer than every
person that you've ever met and you can
only die once they've all died i would
take b because our childhood home is
occupied
currently by our parents it'd be so
frustrating if they couldn't see you
that and
i i don't know if i'd want to hear the
stuff they might say about me dark if
they were to say stuff about me not that
they're talking [ __ ] about well you know
no i know but you'd want but but i
wouldn't even want to know
here's what i wouldn't want i wouldn't
want to overhear
that either of them grieve
mm-hmm that would be very difficult and
not be able to like comfort them by
being like i'm i'm here though i'm it's
okay he does mean currently right not
like go back to your childhood and well
god forbid somebody that would be a
nightmare of some because i thought
about that too if you're
haunting a place that you grew up in
because i think i would if i were to
haunt a place it'd probably be where we
grew up because we lived there for so
long well that's such a shitty thing to
do to haunt your parents well i wouldn't
haunt them in a bad way i'm not saying i
wouldn't like scare them or like
i'm not gonna like well haunt has a
certain i'm not gonna be like
mischievous and like connotation don't
you think
i guess if you say if you necessarily
yeah you're good hauntings yeah but if
you don't qualify it by saying a good
haunt mm-hmm you're going to assume bad
hockey i don't think i don't think so i
think you can haunt yeah
think about i think i think you're wrong
well it's like referring to um what's a
bar that you loved in college
that would be an old haunt of yours
that's different that's a totally
different uh meaning of the word
to haunt someone i i haunt this i bet
they're all degrees of haunting not to
talk about our movie again but every
time i describe the plot of the move the
premise of the movie it's about a ghost
and a woman who's playing the ghost as a
tour guide reena and she starts haunting
the reenactors but i always qualify by
saying it's she's sort of like good good
haunting i do too actually because
otherwise it's like a positive haunting
yeah otherwise you're going to assume
badly that's true but when it comes to
yeah all right you're right you're right
all right so would you rather be a ghost
in your childhood home where nobody that
you know can see i i would assume that
present day present day and i would
assume that it's at least a neutral
haunting okay um i would i would still
try it out i would outlive all my really
yeah
yeah i don't think i'd want to do that i
think i'd but then you wouldn't have to
see i know you know
it's horrible to think of yeah okay well
that would be bad the more i think about
that one that'd be tough outliving
everyone i know because you'd wanna i
mean that's why selfishly i wanna live a
long time of course but i think that's
why i don't wanna have to witness all my
loved ones dying i i oh god either do i
such existential judson johnson jesus
but i think that's why a lot of well you
know judson dealt with the death yeah
and um he's probably thought a lot about
this i i think that's why um people want
to have kids i i know that's a a reason
that's a selfish reason why i want to
have kids and
i really cultivate a relationship with
my younger relatives because
i want to be comforting to have somebody
there when you go when you're on your
way out um
yeah you know the more i'm changing my
mind i'm gonna i'm gonna uh
haunt yeah
because i also was comfortable about
living everybody and then i you know
there's something very
but lonely about the idea of being old
and having all your people gone of
course but it's all and then it's also
comforting knowing that there is in fact
an afterlife you you're you're watching
oh it's just the ability to haunt you're
proof of it that's true you're like no
that's true i already i'm firmly uh wow
i'd completely change something rare
that's a rare one total 180 yeah okay
number two would you rather have to eat
out of a garbage can on the weekdays but
can eat anything you want on the
weekends
or have your brother justin christian
quote
mama bird all your food to you on the
weekends can i curate the garbage can
no you can't curate a garbage can like
it's a spread how do you know
it's a garbage can that's that's why
it's it's like i can't put good food in
the garbage can you can't like place
it's still gross it's in a garbage can i
don't know judson
that's what he said what is it
my question is
what garbage can if it's like a garbage
can behind a random red lobster i'd
rather have you baby bird food into my
mouth
god is that hard wouldn't you
because you might not find anything if
it was my own garbage i would find stuff
that yeah like old rice that i didn't
finish from chinese takeout or something
true i'd find stuff to eat you'd eat
rice all week fine yeah better than you
spitting food in my mouth i know oh god
i'm otherwise i'm making me physically
nauseous it's awful but i think i would
get used to you doing that it would be
awful for the first like two months
month number three be like you just
you'd present your mouth to me it would
it would always be sort of gross but i
think how do you get used to it i think
i'd get used to it i but
you might get used to uh dumpster diving
too no because that there's two there's
too many variables in that there's not
there's not enough guarantee that i
would be able to eat to survive you'd
find a good dumpster you'd find where
the goods like fish heads no but you can
you wouldn't that's my question what
dumpster i think you can i think you can
go in search of better dumpsters oh then
that changes the whole thing like think
about what we used to throw if i can go
from dumpster to dumpster and eventually
land on a delicious dumpster remember
that bagel place i would do that or like
the coffee shop we worked at that's
totally different we you'd live on like
those were
but i would we would take them to the
homeless shelter uh when they were a
dale or like two days old or something
but then after that if they were more
than that we we'd throw them out and
even when they were more than that it
was like it's not that bad i have a
funny story about that oh really
when i was in high school we worked at
the same coffee shop
and i had a bag of
two day old bagels and uh and i put it
in my car it was very messy when i was
in high school and i put the two day old
bag like huge bag of bagels in the
backseat of my car and i was driving
around for i would say a good
two and a half three months and at one
point i was driving my friend who didn't
have his driver's license yet who is now
a physics professor at a very
well-respected university yeah and i was
a very smart person and you don't want
to say who it is no he knows who it is
he knows who it is
and he was in the backseat of my car and
i remember driving and i glanced up at
the rear view mirror and he was eating
something
and we were on our way to get food and i
was like what are you eating we're like
about to go to the diner
and he said oh i couldn't wait i'm so
hungry i said well what are you eating
he said whole bag of bagels back here
and i looked over and i saw that he had
dipped into this old bag of bagels and i
was like how are you eating that he's
like it's pretty good
it's a little stale i guess
my friend is proof that you can you can
eat a three-month-old bagel well there
you go doesn't that then do you want to
change your answer to this would you
rather to judge my i can't answer this
would you rather without at least one
follow up question my question is what
dumps can i pick the dumpster yeah
if it's my own garbage i would pick my
own garbage okay
really great question though judson
number three would you rather kiss a
king cobra snake every night before
sleep or have a tarantula for a bed mate
hmm
tarantula they'd be less dangerous
kissing a king cobra you die you kill
you well i'm assuming that in both
scenarios
you're not going to die it's just
the fear of it right like it's just the
yeah why no you would it's doing it i
think it's doing would you rather kiss a
king cobra every night before sleep
which
you'd bite you on the face but then
let's assume that you're not going to
die from either scenario it's just which
one would be scarier to you well if if
there's an assumption that you're not
going to die then then that eliminates a
lot of the fear
hmm like well no you still get
they can still bite you
i
i don't think i'd be able to fall asleep
knowing that there's a tarantula in the
bed yeah i would say if they're equal
let's say for argument's sake they're
equally dangerous otherwise i really
hate you you just picked the least
dangerous one right let's say they're
crashes aren't that dangerous because
they don't really know but i'm saying
for the sake of the hypothetical and
it's just the act of doing this thing
uh-huh let's say they're equally
dangerous okay in that case i would
i would rather uh kiss the snake
by the way and i'm awake yeah and there
i have more control over it whereas when
i'm sleeping god knows where that trench
is and you can maybe get good enough
like some of those snake charmers at um
holding their mouth shut or something i
don't know like you you could uh
jesus i i'd be so afraid to handle it
cobra i
yeah you would it would have to be if it
were not uh defanged or or um
maybe
maybe i'm not imagining the king cobra
deadly no i know but maybe my see i
picture
snakes uh
right now i'm picturing when i think of
snake i think of the snake in
uh the animated robin robin hood oh my
god so what i'm picturing is not that
scary it's just this kind of thing
yeah
i have like a visceral
reaction when i think of
being around a trap yeah tarantulas are
really
i know and you should because a lot of
people have as pets i i've had friends
who have put um had them on them in my
mind i've seen that right that's that's
amazing at home alone
good questions uh but i would
it depends again i need follow-up
questions if if this were if it were
if the venom had been if they had been
milked um
which is a cool thing to watch if you've
never seen it uh i would pick the snake
and if not i would pick the trenches
because like one of them is going to
kill you and one won't uh okay thanks
again back to justin thanks again for
bringing so many smiles laughs and quote
well that happened
takes to my days and keep fighting and
teasing each other's brothers too it's
really nice you're a fan judson that is
so nice thank you judson and uh
i i'm really sorry to hear that about
your brother and um really
grateful to hear that you um are
appreciating the show and enjoying it
and uh if you also uh want to write in
how to have any would you rathers and
anything you know you know the drill
anything anything uh life is short at
wondering.com i wonder if he ever gets
jetson
major george
when people uh misunderstand his name oh
jets i'm sure he gets justin all the
time i get i've chester a lot when i
mumble my name do you ever get dustin
justin um i'm sure i have i it doesn't
happen enough for me to remember the
last time dustin
justin yeah for sure i've gotten dustin
but dustin again like the justin judson
thing is a less common name
right uh chester a lot hey i'm justin
but but chester
actually recently maybe i've made more
of an effort to to enunciate my name but
um i haven't heard that in a while
chester or maybe it's because chester is
just becoming a much more obsolete name
you don't meet many chesters
how many babies have you met called
chester so thanks again to judson and to
our
wonderful guests yeah the the i'm gonna
call her cat mcnamara i feel i feel
familiar with her now doesn't she also
seem like really easygoing and to the
point where she would not care she seems
to not care about things like names no
she she
said she said that people kept giving
her new nicknames and she's like all
right i guess that's my name now yeah
that's cool she's not precious about her
name it i really like that um i like her
i hope you guys did as well and if you
didn't [ __ ] you
whoa whoa hostile ending
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
it's co-hosted by you christian long and
megan you are it's amazing you are
getting worse at this i didn't think it
was possible produced by megan monaco
senior producer is michelle audio
engineer is sergio enriquez we have two
executive producers on this one
marshall louie and hernan lopez for
wondering bye everyone thank you for
listening
what do you want people to to think of
you how do you want people to think of
you differently and he was probably like
i'm just like they're like what you're
well i have so much more to give i have
so much more to do
you're not like this yeah
intense guy
yeah yeah
silly yeah that's true that's where it
comes from
[Music]
so what's the opposite of the character
that he portrayed on the bachelor he's
the guy who does somersaults
is
but he's also genuinely wait did we miss
hear him
you